hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's edition of
what I eat in a day youtuber refuse I'm
going to be taking a look at British
youtuber grace booth from the YouTube
channel grackle
now grace is a former model who quit
modeling in 2016 to study baking and has
now amassed over 300,000 subscribers on
her YouTube channel
she posts a variety of vlogs what a in
today's and food challenges and reviews
with titles like I recreated an entire
episode of the Great British Bake Off a
show that I am legit obsessed with as
well as things like trying to take talks
and best cooking recipes trying my
subscribers weird food combinations etc
I did see one mukbang which you know I'm
not a fan of but I see more kind of food
experiments than gluttonous calorie
based food challenges so I guess I can
see why it's really entertaining to
watch honestly I'm glad that you guys
introduced me to her channel because I
totally loved her personality and I also
think she looks a little bit like my
younger sister Skye but anyways Before
we jump into my review I want to start
with my general disclaimer that the
information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always seek out the
help of a registered dietitian or
medical professional for your unique
case
let's meet Grace and kick off with a
breakfast she's enjoying in social
isolation because we don't want to get
too soggy now Jessie back in this day he
I think his record for wheats bit is he
has eaten a whole one of these in one
morning and I don't know how many there
are in here I think it's one of these
things you just have to see how many one
it's never to vote let's be real milk on
that and you also you have to put the
layer of sugar because that's obviously
what goes with a bit of Weetabix see
it's already absorbed all the milk I
filled that up so much and okay so I
love how grace is kind of just seeing
how much she wants to eat and then
eating as she goes she'll just add some
more Weetabix
she started with two
it wasn't kind of enough to satisfy her
so she went for another portion super
intuitive and flexible way to eat you
know there were no predetermined
portions in her head here
it was just what she was feeling in that
moment as for the breakfast itself she's
kicking things off old school with
Weetabix cereal which is a whole green
high-fiber cereal that has about 4 grams
of fiber and 4.5 grams of protein for
every two biscuits pretty good I mean I
have not eaten these since I was a kid
at my grandma's house but I bet that I
would probably love them now I love that
we're getting a great amount of fiber
from this breakfast meal with four
biscuits but of course if she wanted to
boost up the satiety factor a little bit
more we could maybe add a little bit
more protein or some fat in here I do
know that grace is dairy-free so she's
using almond milk on hers but almond
milk generally only provides about a
gram of protein per cup
so soy milk for example would be a more
protein rich option with about 7 grams
of protein per cup but otherwise she
could do things like nuts hemp seeds
some soy yogurt or like throw an egg on
the side that would totally do the trick
as well just a suggestion but still a
really amazing breakfast so let's see
what is up for lunch lettuce and tuna
again and I've tasted it I might have
these little some bites I haven't had
the lightly salted ones in years we
would have the sweet chili one square
now we're gonna try it now dad I do have
to say though this isn't these bits
aren't rice krispies
they're rice puffs okay so I feel like
you can't go wrong with a good
old-fashioned not tuna sandwich I mean
you get a good amount of protein and
some healthy fats from the tuna we've
got some fiber from the whole-wheat roll
a little bit of vegetables from the
lettuce and some more extra fat in there
of course from the Mayo she also has an
extra slice of sourdough with some
additional tuna served open-face be
cuz maybe she was still hungry after the
one small sandwich
honestly I love this I think tuna
sandwiches in general are a pretty low
fuss meal that relies on a convenient
high-protein staple that a lot of us are
leaning on right now so I love that
she's keeping it super real and not
worrying about it being fancy or
Instagram a ball not every meal has to
have an avocado flower on it to be
healthy now one of the big questions I
assume I'm going to get about canned
tuna however is in regards to the
mercury content now we know that some
fatty fish is higher in mercury and tuna
steaks are often on that list of fish to
avoid but canned tuna actually has a
fairly low amount of mercury especially
depending on the type white tuna like
albacore has about 0.32 parts per
million of mercury so adults can safely
consume up to about 300 grams per week
light tuna on the other hand is safe to
eat every week in greater proportions
because it has about a third of the
total mercury of albacore so you can
always look for things like skipjack or
yellowfin for the lowest mercury options
anyway love tuna love that it's easy
accessible cost-effective non Instagram
a bowl meal here but if I'm wearing my
dietitian hat I would say we could
probably pump up the vegetables here a
little bit maybe serve it with like a
side salad or maybe just adding in some
more nutrient-dense veggies on top like
some spinach or tomatoes bell peppers
things like that instead of just the
iceberg lettuce again I really
appreciate the relaxed approach to food
more than anything so I want to give
major props to this girl for that but I
know that you guys also want to hear
some actual nutrition suggestions as
well as for the pudding aka the cute
British word for dessert Greece has some
lightly salted chips and a marshmallow
square that she made earlier on in the
day
totally normal healthy portions here so
I'm really happy to see that and again I
love that she's left some room in her
diet for dessert
without it being kind of an
all-or-nothing cheat day situation let's
see what grace has for her afternoon
snack these apples were actually really
hitting the spot at a moment gonna have
this little guy right here love that
beautiful big looking fruit ball and an
apple is always a great afternoon
snacking choice nothing wrong with that
at all but for those of you who may want
to optimize your snacks I like to think
about what I call the hunger crushing
combination of fiber protein and fat and
while a medium-sized Apple does provide
about 4 grams of fiber we can actually
bump up the satiety power a little bit
more by pairing it with some nuts cheese
maybe some yogurt peanut butter etc
let's move on to dinner you know we've
got the what's that Kobe the rice
we've got naan breads happening in here
please can you put my next rice here we
go oh now I'm craving curry okay so
before grace even has dinner she has a
little bit of candy to keep her energy
up until dinner this is kind of why I
had been saying it's a good idea to pair
our snacks with a source of protein or
sorts of fat to really help hold us over
until our next meal because carbs all on
their own can definitely result in some
kind of energy dips shortly after we eat
I would assume that if we paired our
apple that day with some nut butter or
some yogurt we could probably have made
it to dinner without the energy crash
now I'm going to talk more about all of
this at the end of the video so please
do not comment until you see that but I
do think grace is eating intuitively in
the sense that she is smart and she
knows that sugar gives her body energy
it does and she's just responding to
that
intuition but with a little bit of
experimentation when we discover that
refined sugar doesn't keep you very full
for very long so it really only gives
you short-lived satisfaction so I
applaud Grace's rejection of typical
diet culture but I also just want to
offer some kind of basic nutrition
knowledge that may help her get from
meal to meal with just a little bit more
energy okay so as for that beautiful
looking dinner
grace mentions at the top of that clip
that she's usually not a big fan of
curry but she actually really loved that
curry that her family made for dinner I
love when this kind of thing happens
where somebody discovers some kind of
newfound enjoyment and pleasure from a
previously disliked food through
repeated exposure this is basically my
approach to feeding my toddler as well
and if you guys are interested in a
whole video on you know feeding your
picky kids and picky toddlers definitely
leave me a comment below but for reals
this curry really totally does look so
delicious you know we've got some carbs
from the rice we've got protein in the
curry from the meat
homemade samosas a little bit of veg
from the cauliflower and peas
I mean I could probably do with a little
bit more cauliflower here since we're
already getting a fair bit of starch
from the rice and the peas and the
samosa dough but in general this looks
like a really delicious balanced meal
and super flexible especially
considering that she's not usually a big
fan of curry let's take a look at her
snack genuinely my favorite one of my
favorite sweet treats in my top 10
category this what I actually like the
peanut butter and cookie one but I do
enjoy this one too ice cream
got the horse down there and I think I
need to work out these tonight
these are like I just dropped them you
just keep eating and that's fine the
period of my lives oh just great okay I
totally hear what grace is saying about
quarantine kind of being like Christmas
and that you're kind of stuck spending a
lot of time with your family and we tend
to spend a lot more time eating in fact
I have a whole video on social isolation
and emotional eating as it pertains to
kovat so you can check that out right
here but all jokes aside it is very
common to feel like you're struggling
with constant snacking or emotional
eating while in quarantine as you know
you might be laid off or working from
home
having said that Grace's quarantine
eating pattern doesn't look so different
than what we see on a regular day which
we'll get to shortly so hopefully it
hasn't impacted her emotional health too
much as for the snack itself we see that
she's definitely a fan of like a classic
savory and sweet combination which I am
- who isn't but she started with some
vegan Ben and Jerry's added in a little
bit of chips and then went back for the
sweet grapes to finish now on this day
she mainly only had added sugar from a
little bit on the Weetabix and just a
small marshmallow square so I don't
really think it's unreasonable to enjoy
this normal-sized post-dinner snack so
let's take a look at today - these are
very free and vegan all you peeps like
this with it and here they are I mean
they do look funny today but they're so
good oh yeah really hot oh man those
look good okay so day 2 is another
self-isolation what I eat in a day
weekend edition it's actually part of
the same video
gray starts her morning with two baked
from frozen chocolate pastries Pennell
Chocolat
now you will never catch me turning down
a chocolate stuffed pastry in fact I am
totally missing my chocolate croissants
for my local bakery like hardcore right
now but I totally love how casual she is
about food especially coming from an
ex-model but of course you know speaking
with my dietitian hat
obviously this breakfast is a little
lower in nutrition than day one I'm
definitely not saying that you're not
allowed to have a little pastry as part
of your breakfast if that's something
that you truly enjoy but also this was
the weekend and that's basically what I
lived on when I was traveling throughout
Europe so definitely no judgement here
having said that we can think about ways
to boost up the nutrition here to
prevent a mid-morning energy crash
without getting rid of the pastry if
that's what she enjoys so for instance
maybe instead of having just two
pastries we could pair one with some soy
yogurt or some eggs or we could stuff it
with some peanut butter instead of
chocolate okay so you probably want the
peanut butter with the chocolate let's
be real but there are definitely a lot
of ways that we can boost up the
nutrition without losing out on the
pleasure that is that heavenly weakened
chocolate pastry having said all of that
grace I get you girl I mean we are in
self-isolation right now our normal
routines are getting majorly stretched
and challenged and that's okay do what
you got to do to bring joy to your day
and I say a croissant is definitely a
good way to do that
let's take a look at lunch are you ready
for the moment of truth some roast
potatoes homemade of course some carrots
and cabbage some stuffing some roasted
parsnips and some chicken and we'll have
some mustard this
and nuts milk bites so good with the hot
water
oh man it really is like Christmas in
isolation but we're seeing more
vegetables so that is awesome and here
we have some protein from the chicken
we've got complex carbs from the roasted
potatoes and maybe some of the stuffing
depending on the bread as well as lots
of edge from the carrots cabbage and
parsnips and one of these little fruit
and nut milk bars for dessert this looks
like a beautifully balanced meal that
isn't in any way diet e or restrictive
so I guess my only suggestion would be
to kind of just watch the salt the rest
of the day I mean salt can like sneak up
on you and I know it's hard to believe
but this meal contains about half of
Grace's total sodium intake for the day
mainly from the stuffing and the gravy I
got that things do not taste the same
without gravy I hear ya so I would
probably do this too but
my gentle suggestion would be to offer
lower sodium variety make it from
scratch which she may have I don't know
and then you can use less salt or just
pay attention to your salt the rest of
the day
again these kinds of salty meals or
salty days are totally fine in
moderation I really don't think this is
a big deal but again I'm just trying to
offer some general nutrition advice to
kind of keep in the back of your head
for planning overall dietary patterns
let's take a look at her snack I'm gonna
have this up ooh with some bits of
crunchy which if you don't have this
cough you need to because there's a
mid-afternoon snack okay so for day two
snack grace does pay her applet with a
spread and a delicious cookie flavored
spread at that which side note I am
low-key obsessed with buying any time
I'm in Europe or the UK it is delicious
but from a nutrition perspective maybe
not the
nutritious choice particularly in the
context of Grace's day since she already
ended her last meal not long ago with a
sweet chocolate bar now I want to make
it clear that I'm not saying that this
is bad and hey if she was craving the
cookie butter cuz it is delicious
that my all means go for it there is
100% room for all of these types of
sweets but again if I'm just speaking
from a snack optimization perspective
since we did see what happened with the
energy crash on day one I would ideally
choose like a higher protein spread
maybe something like yogurt or nut
butter let's take a look at dinner I
mean dinner dinner and I've actually has
some frozen things so in here I had a
frozen burrito and a frozen pizzas I
made a video so I'm just put back into
the oven mmm pizza my minutes for the
crust for the crust the top tip if you
haven't got any garlic butter to Han
just don't you crusted mayo
okay so I believe grace just said that
she had made the pizza and the burritos
and then froze them which is great since
I do know a lot of throws and varieties
are attempting to be higher in salt I
mean let's be real frozen commune's
foods are totally fine in moderation and
I rely on them sometimes as well
especially on super busy nights but like
I said earlier with the gravy if we're
having one higher sodium meal then I
would probably just try to be more
mindful about choosing lower sodium
options the rest of the day by the way
if you want a whole video on salt let me
know and I can definitely work on that
soon so leave me a comment below but as
for the burrito Pizza combo I mean what
can I say sounds like a dream meal I
love both burritos and pizza so I know
it would be cruel to make a person
choose but nutritionally it may help
grace to pair one of them with some more
vegetables to kind of balance this meal
out and before you say well a salad is
just not as filling as a burrito
uh noted but if we added in some avocado
not seeds and a higher fat dressing
we could easily bump up the satiety
factor in a salad to meet Grace's
caloric needs let's take a look at our
bedtime snack food for some reason I'm
not really some cocoa pop and I'll sort
through that afterwards okay so this is
a bit of a random selection of goodies
again hitting both her sweet and salty
cravings which is great we've got a
little bit of cured meat that I think
she just had a little taste of some
cocoa puffs and some prawn cocktail
chips again a fair bit of salt I will
say because you know these are processed
foods but all of this together is
probably just around the 300 calorie
mark which is a totally reasonable size
for any kind of bedtime snack honestly
I'm not too worried let's take a look at
day three the breakfast is this the best
cereal ever from Aldi
it is dairy-free and it's basically like
crave it's got a hazelnut flavored
filling a hot water of course and a bowl
with honor milk so here we go okay so
when day three gray starts her morning
with some cocoa pillow cereal which she
has with almond milk now a lot of
breakfast cereals nowadays are fortified
with vitamins and minerals which is
great but of course some cereals do
still tend to be a little bit higher in
sugar
this particular cereal has about 11
grams of sugar per serving with just a
little over a gram of fiber and two
grams of protein not a big breakfast and
considering the kind of fast digesting
carbs without a lot of fiber going on or
fat or protein slow it down I would
probably think she'd be a little hungry
soon after this again I am NOT
taking enjoyed foods away so one thing I
sometimes recommend if you know you love
your sugary cereal is to mix it with a
higher fiber lower sugar option
something like all brand or some oatmeal
or those Weetabix that we already saw
her enjoying you could also serve it
with like a higher protein soy yogurt
instead of almond milk for a little bit
more approaching in there I am all about
eating what you truly love but also
about knowing that having just sugary
cereal all on its own
will probably leave me feeling really
hungry and unsatisfied soon after again
I'm gonna be talking in a lot more
detail about how this all fits into
intuitive eating towards the end of the
video so stay tuned for that
I'm also getting the sense that hot
water is Grace's morning beverage of
choice and we don't really know why
maybe she just prefers it to cold water
so I'm definitely not knocking it but
there actually is some evidence to
suggest that drinking hot water may have
some health benefits so for example some
older studies have found that consuming
hot liquids may reduce feelings of
stress and anxiety and may also improve
nasal congestion but other than that I
mean there's an a whole lot of evidence
to support hot water versus cold water
for hydration so my recommendation is to
drink what you love and what you enjoy
and to just focus on hydrating enough
let's take a look at lunch graces would
be honest grace it's got mayonnaise at
the bottom tanks here we go that is a
beast
these flavor rings who loops spicy
they're really I see what that like and
then what you do you dip it in the hot
water stir it around goes the melty
those chocolates look really good okay
so for day three lunch we have a fish
cake
sandwich with a side of chips and a
little bit of chocolate for a dessert
looks so delicious and again I love the
relaxed casual and easy approach to food
you know she's got some protein from the
fish cakes we got fat in the Mayo carved
from the bun and a little veg again the
only small concern I have is that this
tends to be a little higher in sodium
because I think those are prepared fish
cakes plus we've got the chips and the
olives in there honestly even bread has
a surprising amount of sodium a typical
bun has around 200 milligrams of sodium
which equals about 10 percent of your
daily sodium eats for the day which is
crazy right I mean I don't know I never
even thought about salt and bread until
I started feeding my son solids and I
realized how much sodium is usually in
bread so it's just something to kind of
keep in the back of your mind when
you're looking for a lower sodium option
anyways other than that I would say that
there's definitely room for grace to a
little bit more veggies to our meals on
top of the amounts that we're already
getting from a little bit of arugula and
the small bit of cherry tomatoes again I
do not believe in strict food rules but
for those of you who like a little bit
of structure I'd like to think about
filling half of my plate with vegetables
a quarter with starch and a quarter with
protein so if we consider that I would
say we would want to kind of tweak the
proportions just a little bit to boost
up the fiber and antioxidants I also
like to focus on adding nutritious foods
in rather than taking foods away so even
if we were to not take anything away
from a grace as having but rather to add
in more veg we would see a significant
boost in potassium in this meal this is
important because sodium and potassium
have an inverse relationship meaning
that consuming more potassium in the
diet aids in the removal of excess
sodium from the body and thereby helps
to kind of lower blood pressure
in addition potassium also helps to
relax blood vessel walls which may also
contribute to lowering blood pressure so
if we're having a higher sodium
ile adding in some more leafy vegetables
could definitely help balance things out
again I would bet that blood pressure is
not a huge concern for grace but it
might be for some of the people that
she's enjoying her meals with let's take
a look at her snack okay
so bird day 3 snack grace is having some
chocolate covered pretzels with some
grapes I'm kind of obsessed with
chocolate-covered pretzels because I
love the sweet salty appeal and it's
definitely obvious that grace is a
chocolate lover and girl no judgment
here
I am also totally need of my daily fix
but of course I am just mindful of what
happened on day one with the energy
crash so maybe instead of the grapes if
she wanted to keep the chocolate
pretzels maybe we could dip them in some
nut butter that would be delicious and
also really satisfying things like that
I know I know I'm sounding a little bit
like a broken record but this whole
snack balance thing but hopefully this
is helpful for you guys who are trying
to plan out really satisfying snacks
let's take a look at what she has for
dinner we've got an eruv guacamole and
they are a chicken thing a layer of
salad and then I'm gonna put this and
I'm gonna no no it's like the snack wrap
I got from Taco Bell know you fold it in
it's not gonna stick well I'm having it
it's so nice with the crunchy and creamy
gravy
yeah mavin another slice that's what I
want okay so I cannot tell you how
excited I was to see that big bowl of
salad which I'm not gonna lie it's
usually something I dread seeing when I
do these youtuber reviews because let's
be real that is all I see but I will
definitely say that this meal is looking
super balanced and I'm loving it now we
are also seeing things end with two
pieces of chocolate cake which I'm not
gonna lie supplies about a hundred grams
of sugar from this meal alone
and I am all about having dessert and I
love what appears to be a really healthy
and relaxed approach to food so I am not
about to take away anybody's cake but I
would say if we're finding ourselves
facing those sugar spikes and energy ups
and downs there are a few little ways
that we could tweak dessert to balance
that out so for example maybe we could
try making the cake with almond flour
for some more fiber and some fat or
topping it with nut butter instead of a
really sugary frosting another thing you
could do is serve it with yogurt instead
of serving it with sweetened cream these
are just small little changes that of
course let you have your cake and eat it
too without the sugar crash soon after
now before we do our final tallies let's
see what grace is having as her bedtime
a snack
Carly a sassy I just raised how much
children I've had today
bunju on so it's an excuse he as much
trouble as I want okay and this is a
free from salted caramel chocolate slab
I've never tried this from for Harry by
new stomachs at the same time it's a
Saturday every day is different
sometimes I eat loads of sweets and
chocolate sometimes those are crisps
sometimes emails are fruit vegetables
every day is different
that is why living is great please
become comments I don't even need to
justify why tea like this or how I eat
like this or anything like that
it's what my body wants it's what he
needs so peace out like okay what can we
say the girl loves her chocolate and
Greg's does mention that she doesn't
need to justify what she eats because
this is what her body wants and it's
what her body needs and she eats
differently every day and that's why
life is so great and to that I say
amazing I cannot deny Grace's
nutritional needs and as I am not seeing
any restriction and rules I also do not
doubt that she is a pretty good
relationship with food this is really
refreshing like
I actually love this but before people
watch this and say well if that's a good
relationship with food I don't want it
because it must be just eating junk all
the time I want a flag that most people
maybe not grace but most people would
maybe not feel their best
eating chocolate multiple times a day
most people may feel better if they
paired their Apple with can almond
butter instead of cookie butter and a
lot of people may feel better if their
digestive systems were working optimally
because they were getting enough fiber
through lots of colorful fruits and
vegetables I am not discounting that
grace may actually feel really great
eating this way and this is working for
her and also that like she says she eats
differently every single day but when I
talk about nutrition I talk about
general population trends and most
people would probably be able to achieve
the same sense of eating what their body
wants and what their body needs and
ultimately eating intuitively while
eating a little less sugar salt or
saturated fat this is a highly
individual thing and it sounds like
grace is doing what works for her and
honestly I think that's great
now let's get to the big questions in
general is this way of eating balanced
now as I've said multiple times it is so
nice to see a normal intuitive eater
even if there are a few things that I
might tweak from a nutritional
perspective that would make these meals
more satiating and nutritionally dense
for the general population after taking
a look at Grace's nutritional analysis
Grace's diet provides 30 to 40% of her
total calories coming from fat which is
at the higher end of the 20 to 35%
macronutrient range and while grace is
getting some really healthy fats from
her diet from foods like tuna and the
fish in the fish cakes which would
contribute to this amount I would say
that a lot of it is probably in the form
of saturated fat from chocolate cakes
and other desserts in fact she is
getting about twice the amount of
recommend saturated fat in her day now
like I've said before
the research on saturated fat is super
controversial with some research
suggesting that it may have negative
implications for heart health while
other research suggesting that there is
no correlation it also may depend on the
type of saturated fat so as I've said
before if you're interested in a deep
dive on saturated fat leave me a comment
below so that I can bump that up in my
priorities it's quite a beast to cover
personally I'm not really that concerned
with saturated fat for someone young and
healthy like grace but officially it's
still considered a nutrient of concern
and something to watch for the general
population what I would say the research
is much more clear on is the risk of
excessive sodium intakes and grace is
consuming up to 48 milligrams of sodium
a day which is twice the recommendation
again for young people like grace
probably not a big deal other than maybe
the fact that it could cause bloating
and some symptoms of dehydration that
can be uncomfortable but like I said
might not be a deal breaker for grace
however I'm just trying to use this
video like all of my videos as kind of
teachable moments to point out that
things like excessive sodium intakes can
increase long-term cardiovascular risks
like high blood pressure and risk of
stroke most of the salt and Graces diet
is coming from processed foods like
chips sauces and other convenience foods
which I'm not suggesting that we have to
cut out or take away all of these foods
are totally fine in moderation and I
love that grace isn't scared of these
foods like so many youtubers that I
review this is so so key but rather if
we were to just kind of add a bit more
fresh or frozen veggies to some of
Graces meals we would probably see a
huge boost in potassium and other
nutrients to really balance that sodium
out and we may even displace some of the
calories from high salt foods without
even trying finally we are seeing quite
a bit of added sugar in Grace's diet
which of course long term is associated
with increased risk of heart disease
diabetes
some cancers etc probably not a concern
for a young healthy girl like grace so I
am just happy to see a refreshing
balanced flexible approach to dessert
but I would say it can negatively impact
energy levels by causing those quick
spikes in blood sugar followed by the
dreaded crash we even saw that happen
when grace kind of needed the extra
candy fix before dinner in order to give
her an extra energy boost because
Chicana was feeling herself fading like
I said previously consuming moderate
amounts of things like candy and
chocolate is perfectly normal and
healthy I am all for it if that's line
that you enjoy but we just don't want
these foods to displace a lot of
important nutrients and foods like
fruits and veggies and when we do enjoy
them we ideally want to pair them with
some slower digesting foods that will
keep us fuller for longer
assuming that doesn't deter from our
enjoyment of them aside from these minor
nutritional concerns which again are
really generalized nutritional
recommendations for the public as grace
very well may feel great eating this way
I do really need to give credit where
credit is due
grace does seem to have a pretty normal
and healthy relationship with food which
is so nice to see in a wellness world
filled with crazy food rules and
restrictions
despite being dairy-free which may or
may not be due to lactose intolerance we
don't really know but we don't see any
restriction going on here she seems to
eat what she genuinely enjoys and in
portions that she's actually hungry for
spaced appropriately throughout the day
if she feels like having an extra
serving of something because she's
hungry or because it's just really
delicious she gives herself that
permission I think there is a lot that
we can learn from grace in terms of
listening to her hunger and fullness
cues and balancing those satiety and
satisfaction factors now are there any
problematic claims or assumptions made
by this channel I wouldn't necessarily
say that there are any direct public
claims or assumptions made on Grace's
channel or the what I in a day videos
that I reviewed her wedding-day videos
were pretty straight for
in terms of simply sharing what she eats
with her viewers I mean I didn't pick up
on any type of diet e-language
or misinformation which is something
that I always appreciate she also
encourages eating what your body wants
and what your body needs and as I've
said before there there's really no way
for me to know if this is truly what
Grace's body needs or if these meals or
snacks are things that she's enjoying at
a habit boredom emotion eating or access
only grace knows this so I do have to
respect that she knows her body best but
to those who are concerned that eating
intuitively then means eating just like
a lot of chocolate and chips I would say
that listening to hunger and fullness is
just one part of the picture intuitive
eating is often a lot about
experimentation and collecting data on
how foods make you feel so maybe it
means one day trying out eating a bigger
portion of veggies and a little less
sugar to see if you feel better I know
for me when I was a teenager in high
school aka well before I was studying
nutrition I would eat a big chocolate
chip cookie from the cafeteria every day
for breakfast it wasn't until I
graduated and started having like
oatmeal or peanut butter toast at home
that I even realized that I had been
feeling kind of crappy eating just
cookies every single day I mean maybe I
was also just getting older and
therefore my body was just less
forgiving but still this was only
learned through experimentation and what
I would call data collection so again
this may genuinely feel good and normal
to grace right now and the higher
amounts of salt and saturated fat and
sugar might not slow her down but I
would say that most people with a little
more experimentation maybe some age and
experience in their intuitive eating
journey may start to collect some data
that eating more fruits and more
vegetables and less processed foods may
just inherently feel better to them in
the long term so what I am saying is
I do not want you to ever restrict ever
I don't want anyone to watch this and
think that that is my message because I
am actively and frequently applauding
grace for not restricting I am honestly
just so relieved to review a youtuber
who doesn't have a laundry list of rules
to eat by every single day but I would
encourage grace and others who feel that
they need a lot of sugar or salt
- maybe experiment to see how other
foods feel to focus on adding foods
rather than focusing on restricting and
taking foods away and then see how that
really affects your energy digestion and
general effect and when you want
chocolate eat chocolate and again see
how it makes you feel all of this is
just judgment free data to help you get
to know your unique body and your unique
needs the best I know I also mention
that grace has a number of food
challenge videos on our channel which in
general is not my favorite YouTube trend
however I will say that Grace's videos
tend to have a more creative and take a
more modest approach to food challenges
so for instance in the video titled
mokbang with dad she eats a total of two
dairy-free donuts not 10,000 calories in
one day in another video titled milk
bang with my brother they share a
reasonable amount of pizza nuggets and
cinnamon bites like a normal Saturday
night in so Grace's milk bangs are
definitely more aligned with the
original intention of the concept rather
than being about eating as much as one
possibly can just for views finally what
should we take away from grackles
channel honestly I really enjoy watching
grace she isn't claiming to be a
nutrition expert she's just a normal
regular 23 year old girl and her channel
represents her fun personality without
the drama and misinformation I like that
she isn't hung up on restriction or food
rules or even worrying about the
judgment that others may have on her
diet she's just having fun with food and
eating things she loves I specifically
love
some of her cooking videos like
recreating my family's favorite
restaurant meals and making Bon Appetit
some gourmet Girl Scout cookies she is
definitely entertaining to watch in
conclusion I am 100% all for Grace's
no-nonsense message of eating foods that
your body wants and your body needs do I
think the vast majority of people could
eat this amount of chocolate and chips
and feel really great probably not
especially those of us who aren't in our
20s anymore but the benefit of not
dieting is not only a better emotional
relationship with food but also a more
resilient metabolism so please grace
keep doing what you're doing is it the
perfect diet no but I kind of like that
about her
and I think she is an amazing role model
she's just eating based on the
information that her mind and her body
is giving her and that information may
very well be perfectly sound to her or
maybe it just needs a little bit more
data to fully understand what feels best
and all of that just takes time bottom
line I say follow grackle because she is
fun and an entertaining youtuber and I
think she's a great role model for a lot
of young girls who are struggling in a
world obsessed with diet and appearance
and that is all for today folks so if
you like this video please be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with who you'd like to see me
review next subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]